the US authorities are going after
another European Bank New York State is
suing Barclays over alleged fraud in the
marketing of its dark pools the bank
runs one of Wall Street's largest dark
pools according to a complaint filed
yesterday by New York Attorney General
Eric Schneiderman Barclays falsified
marketing materials to hide how much
high-frequency traders were buying and
selling Barclays is now said to be
losing its dark pool trading customers
so how did the government build its case
and are there more like this on the way
joining me right now New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman welcome
attorney Schneiderman thank you glad to
be here let's talk about this case first
of all how did this come to be how did
you begin this investigation we started
looking at issues related to
high-frequency trading and firms that
did business with high-frequency traders
beginning of last year and we've had
several matters where we have dealt with
the issue of early release of consumer
confidence surveys and corporate
earnings and most of the time when we've
confronted market participants they've
changed their behavior we haven't had to
sue in this case we discovered a pattern
of fraud at it Barclays in connection
with its dark pool that over the last
really you know six months or so and
some whistleblowers came forward from
who had been insiders and brought us
some documents and I write that said
that he tried to do something he
apparently was let go after having
alerted some clients well he refused to
alter data one of the things Barclays
was doing was changing the data and
misleading clients about how many of the
trades were actually filled in Barclays
own dark pool they were saying they had
all this elaborate propaganda saying oh
we feel we go to whatever market is best
for the client we always go for the best
price the best fill and in fact the data
that this director was preparing for a
big institutional investor showed that
seventy-five percent of all the trades
were filled in Barclays dark pools
suggesting they weren't really getting
the things they were taking to
themselves because you know you get
compensation right for having done
trade right so and we now know that they
were also allowing a high frequency
traders access so essentially they were
attracting fish into their pond with the
promise that there were no predators but
they were inviting the Predators into
they direct they told this director you
got to change this number from 75% to
35% out-and-out lie he refused to do it
and he was fired so the several whistle
whistle blowers have come forward and it
was a case where we understood the fraud
to be ongoing and we proceeded quickly
to bring the complaint because we have
documents as recently as a couple of
months ago showing even in response to
our your press reports and my comments
about high frequency trading in March
and April oh the people inside Barclays
saying hey they're all these reports out
there here are some talking points to
rebut them and there was a bunch of more
misleading information so it was an
ongoing fraudulent just to point out
what they have said you know Barclays
that issued a statement saying we take
these allegations very seriously
Barclays has been cooperating with the
New York Attorney General and the SEC
and has been examining this matter
internally the integrity of the markets
is a top priority of Barclays have they
been cooperating with you enough well no
we subpoenaed their records and we got
some production in some production was
more more difficult to come by and we
filed a lawsuit against them so that the
facts of the complaint really speak for
themselves in addition to the deception
we just discussed about I what portion
of their trades were being filled in
their own dark pool we also discovered a
pretty blatant deception about the the
amount of high-frequency trading that
was going on in their dark will they
repeatedly represented to customers and
investors it was less than ten percent
was really de minimis and their internal
numbers show that it was much greater
than that in fact they were out trying
to lure high-frequency traders into
their dark pool by offering them
informational advantages giving them
information essentially the hft s were
trading for no cost in Barclays dark
pools so it was misrepresentations about
the predatory nature of the trading in
the pool and there were these are their
terms predatory toxic aggressive traders
they had a rating system that they
touted called the liquid liquidity
profiling system and it was really a
sham and one barclay director used the
word sham and described
let's back up for a minute for the
viewer who doesn't understand for
example what a dark fool really is i
mean the the defense of the banks is
that they would say we need these dark
pools for clients who need to do very
very big trades and don't want people
front-running those trades so it gives
you a certain amount of anonymity and
secrecy in in putting a large block of
stock on the market and so therefore
doesn't have such an influence on the
price walk us through what a dark pool
is and white sure you see them as a
problem now well and maybe not
necessarily a problem we're not we're
not condemning all dark pools we're just
saying that if you have a dark pool and
as you said if i want to buy 20 million
shares of facebook if i start buying in
the rate an open exchange everyone can
see that i'm buying the price will go up
and move away from me so the theory of a
dark pool is that i can buy there and
the rest of the markets not going to see
that I want to make such a massive
purchase the problem is in this case
that Barclays was misleading its
investors about what was actually going
on in its dark pool the degree to which
it was filling orders in other venues
where customers could get better prices
and the fact that they really were
attracting predatory traders and again
this is Barclays own internal
terminology they talked about toxic
predatory aggressive traders they
misrepresented the amount of that
trading in their dark pool it was as
though they were letting attracting the
efficient to the pond and then giving
fishing licenses to the hft s so with
vinyl client at Barclays and I want to
buy a very large amount of stock or sell
a large amount i would go to Barclays
and they would say okay we would do this
in a dark pool and they should
theoretically be using any dark pool not
just their own well what they
represented to investors was that they
would look considering all the
circumstances the need to maintain some
privacy but also where you could get the
best Phil where you could get the best
order their marketing materials
repeatedly represented as all exchanges
are now electronically linked that they
would go to the best exchange when the
data was assembled and it came out that
seventy-five percent of the trades
in their own dark pool which is a number
that's impossible to achieve if you're
actually searching for the best price
for every customer they directed one of
their employees to falsify that data at
its and have it say thirty-five percent
for them Eric I mean if they
theoretically stand to make more money
right if the trade goes through the
block goes through their own dark pool
as opposed to farming it out to someone
else's yeah it was clear from the
documents we got in the testimony
received that they had a project in this
particular division the the equities
electronic trading division that there
they called it the franchise the dark
pool they wanted to be the largest in
the United States they want to attract a
lot of people into it obviously if you
have a big dark pool you save because
you don't have to pay fees to other
exchanges and other other banks and that
was one of their projects so they
attracted people in with marketing
materials that suggested this is the
safest place you can do business with de
minimis high frequency trading de
minimis toxic activity and they
represented that through this liquidity
profiling system they would throw out
traders who were overly aggressive they
never threw out one single trader no
matter how predatory their conduct was
what is your sort of gut reaction here I
mean how prevalent is this on Wall
Street what you've seen it Barclays is
this happening in other institutions
well this is a pretty flamboyant example
of out-and-out fraud against your
investors we don't believe that's
happening across so you wouldn't
understand a lot of banks might be
incentivized to have these trades happen
in house as opposed to add a house and
that's fine you just can't lie to your
customers and say oh six percent of the
trading here falls into these categories
that quote that are predatory or toxic
these are Barclays terms when it's about
25 or 30 or 40 percent have you gone
through the numbers have you looked to
see just exactly how many trades really
were happening internally versus
externally we've got their own
documentation we know that they knew the
number it's the percentage that they
were in their dark pool in excess of 75
percent of all of the trades for all the
customers they took in were executed in
their own dark pool and when they saw
that number they knew it would scare
away institutional investors so they
they actually after they fired the guy
who wouldn't reduce the number to
thirty-five percent they
this false information to the investor
anyway and that's why that was one of
the things that cause us to feel that we
had to move rapidly to follicles so what
kind of finds do anticipate will be
imposed and what would you like to see
to discourage this kind of behavior at
barclays in any other institution out
there well it's too early to tell we
just follow the complaint we're now have
a period of discovery part of it depends
on what kind of injunctive relief we get
or what barclays does so if they
immediately clean their act up that
affects our view of the fine they should
pay but we're in court now and we're
looking forward to moving ahead in it
but now that we're in front of a judge
all right well uh Eric Schneiderman
thank you very much for joining me and
explaining out the complaint that's the
New York Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman thank you